on December 20th it's his time at Shiva  story Star Wars the rise of Skywalker  heard a pg-13 in five days  this will be the final word in the story  of Skywalker  Star Wars the rise of Skywalker rated  pg-13  [Music]  I know who you are  I know the rest of your story  the rise of Skywalker radio pg-13 get  tickets now in nine days below have I  agree  nothing can prepare you  Star Wars the rise of Skywalker hurry to  pg-13 it's too dangerous  I need to go alone we're all in this to  the end  we've got friends out there good people  will fight if we leave them they've  taken enough of us now we take the war  to them the final battle  again Star Wars the rise of Skywalker  video pg-13 get tickets now  let the final battle begin  we won't surrender we make our last  stand  starwars the rise of Skywalker get  tickets now  you